vous avez vous-même
dressé merci la parole est à Monsieur
Yve Albarello merci monsieur le
Président ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'Intérieur
monsieur le ministre en décembre dernier
je vous ai posé une question sur les
mosquées salafistes radicalisé suite à
la fermeture de la mosquée de la ni
surmarne comm unee de ma circonscription
permettez-moi de revenir sur la mosquée
de Laan surmarne plusieurs démarches
juridiques des musulmans pour faire
réouvrir ce lieu de culte ont tout échou
la dernière en date a été rejetée par le
tribunal administratif le 30 septembre
dernier à la suite de cette fermeture
les prières de rue se déroule C fois par
jour sur l'espace public malgré
plusieurs saisines du maire courrier
rendez-vous en préfecture et au
ministère la situation s'enlise et les
prières continuent à se faire devant une
école de la République dans un quartier
prioritaire de la politique de la ville
cela doit cesser la ville de l'agis
SURMAR n'est laissée seule face à ce
problème national l'État doit agir soit
monsieur le ministre vous considérez que
le culte s'exercer dès aujourd'hui sans
risque de radicalisme et vous permettez
la réouverture du lieu de culte soit
vous considérez que ce n'est pas le cas
et vousit cesser ces prières dite de rue
par ailleurs il est inacceptable que les
élus municipaux apprennent par voie de
presse dans leur vie 10 fichiers S et un
total de 40 sur la communauté
d'agglomération de Marn gondoir il faut
empêcher ces personnes répertoriées dans
ce fichier de faire du prosélitisme de
surcroit lorsqu'il s'agit de quartier
prioritaire de politique de la ville
tout comme la la ville ne peut se passer
de l'état l'État ne peut se passer des
collectivité locale dans ce domaine la
solution la création d'un officiel entre
les collectivités et vos services
spécialisés afin qu'il y ait des
échanges d'information mais actuellement
reste le problème des prières de rue
alors ma question est qu allez-vous
donner l'ordre à la police nationale de
faire cesser ces prières dans les rues
de la surmne la parole est à Monsieur
Bernard casen ministre de l'Intérieur
monsieur le député je veux profiter de
cette question nous en avons souvent
parlé ensemble pour apporter un certain
nombre de précision d'abord oui j'ai
procédé à la
dissolution après avoir présenté cette
dissolution au Conseil des ministres de
trois associations qui soutendaient le
fonctionnement d'une mosquée radicalisée
et gravement radicalisé je rappelle que
l'imam de cette mosquée qui a rejoint
l'Égypte en
2012 appelé provoqué au terrorisme que
au sein de cette mosquée il y avait des
individus qui incitaient des jeunes à
partir sur le théâtre des opérations
terroristes et lorsque j'ai procédé à la
dissolution de ces
associations après que le Conseil des
ministres en a décidé du principe avec
l'appui très fort du président de la
République et du premier minre il y a eu
des commentaires par voix de presse je
sais pas si vous souvenez des
commentaires notamment de collectivité
locale qui s'interrogaient sur la
pertinence de cette décision donc je
tiens à vous redire ici très
solennellement que aussi longtemps que
ce gouvernement agira et que je serai
dans ma responsabilité nous fermerons
les lieux de cul dans lesquels on
appelle et provoque au terrorisme
premier point deuxième point vous me
dites est-ce que faut recréer un lieu de
culte parce que c'est la demande de la
municipalité je la connais moi on ne
peut pas me demander à la fois de fermer
des lieux de cut parce qu'en leur sein
il y a des individus qui incitent au
terrorisme et me demander de réouvrir
ces lieux pour qu'il n'y ait pas de
prière de rue parce que c'est la demande
qui m'est faite par un certain nombre
d'élus municipaux dès lors monsieur le
député que je n'ai pas la garantie que
entre la nouvelle structure et
l'ancienne ceux qui l'ont dirigé les
avoirs je parle des avoirs et ce n'est
pas neutre et ce n'est pas sans hasard
ne seront pas transmis parce que je veux
que le nouveau lieu de culte soit un
lieu de culte qui correspondent à une
conception de l'islam républicaine par
conséquent dès lors que j'aurai cette
garantie nous irons de l'avant pour
éviter qu'il y ait des prières et quant
aux policiers ils ont